[Music]
what would it take for you to feel
secure more the movie all the money in
the world is getting major awards season
buzz and is being called a
first-of-its-kind in an unprecedented
move for Hollywood director Ridley Scott
recast a major role in the movie he
replaced scandalized actor Kevin Spacey
with Christopher Plummer all with just a
few weeks to reshoot and edit the film
six hours a new letters benedict et
spoke with Scott and the cast about the
whirlwind process we had a half hour
meeting and the boardroom and so I said
may I may I read it I really I really
would have said yes anyway I hadn't read
it because I wanted to work with him
very much so
I did read it and said yes sir boom then
we were off to the races
Wow tell me the process of making that
decision so Harvey it was enough that oh
we're going into the crucible here and I
thought this is gonna really open
everything up and I knew when as soon as
they hit Kevin it was gonna blow wide
open I might I mean contact my Pradas
saying we should drink a stirs right now
we shoot right now we'll be out for the
same day how scary was it though
recasting this shooting making all the
calls to tell everybody I'm gonna do
this again what's that what's about his
agreement everything else is a matter of
efficiency time for you to do whatever
it is he pays you to do what did you
find out you would have to reshoot some
of these scenes you know it's funny if
you were like when did you get the call
yeah that's it I didn't get a call we
were in New York so I'd go back to my
hotel for lunch and really Scott is
sitting in my dining room table he tells
me what he's doing and I was like I get
it and I was like well first and
foremost as long as we're making sure
that the respect and sensitivity is
shown to the victims here and then also
he wanted to make sure they honored
everybody else's work I mean you have
all these artists that worked on this
movie and he wanted to make sure that
their work was seen and so he said he
was gonna reshoot the movie so I said
okay
cancel Thanksgiving I walked on the set
and I met Chris that day he was already
in wardrobe and makeup in front of the
camera we said hello literally in front
of the camera as Ridley was saying
rolling and we started shooting how I
view the two things other people can't
or won't do
[Music]